previously on TV sentence I swear Fiona
you're nothing like anyone I've ever met
you make me want to enjoy my life again
you had me at hello for printer
preparation pushes pages to perilously
plummet beep the paper span this is
Michael Scott I am the regional manager
of Dunder Mifflin paper products Michael
is the regional manager but he's only
shown to manage the one location in
Scranton and we even hear later that
there's a Stamford branch nearby that
also has a manager so what's with the
nonsensical nomenclature right off the
bat the office I know this was all the
way back in 2005 is there any reason to
have a no-smoking sign this large in a
very insular office space and yet
another sign by Pam what the hell's
going on with the smoking in Scranton
that they need this much signage I must
know I've I've been at Dunder Mifflin
for 12 years welcome to the wonderful
world of fake documentary sitcoms we're
breaking the fourth wall and exposition
are no longer sins but part of the
charming humor
oh man I almost believed it myself when
I said it don't let the incredible
writing fool you a plot sheet is still
cheap also why Dunder Mifflin why this
branch oh sure I've heard the
revisionist history that a former
employee had committed suicide and the
documentary crew was there to film the
co-workers reactions but aside from how
dark that is for this show it's never
mentioned once in the very first episode
wouldn't you think if that were the
point it might come up at least once and
the interviews I'm thinking it's more
likely a convenient excuse for Jim to
give knowing looks to the camera and
also because the Brits did it that way
and we wanted to show him up I think
that pretty much sums it up one thing
this show never does a great job of
making you believe is that Michael Scott
would be put in charge of anything
sitcom rules and all but even married
with children made us buy that Al Bundy
would occasionally be able to sell a
pair of shoes see we have the entire
floor I hear that might be news to the
Vance refrigeration just a fax oh damn
this is from corporate the fact that
Michael didn't do a just the facts man
dragnet joke is completely out of
character considering he just did a take
on bambam from the Flintstones like five
seconds ago the outdated idiocy would be
right on point
no gifts damn these two are gold
together that the rest of the cast the
writing just removed the sin already my
job is to speak to clients on the phone
about quantities I'm boring myself just
talking about this well it's better than
not saying anything at all I suppose
wait that gives me an idea for a movie
also just say you're in sales instead of
this protracted diatribe about the
minutiae of your responsibilities Jim
gets a lot of goodwill but he's
ultimately kind of a hipster doofus also
also what's the dress code at Dunder
Mifflin and in Dwight where suit coats
with Jim and Michael are in their
shirtsleeves and Jim always has that top
button unbuttoned I'm just wondering if
this is as far as Jim's pushed that coat
or if he could show up in like a
jockstrap and a t-shirt with no
repercussions those aunts ran until
three years prior to this episode and
don't come at me with outdated
repetitive ad concepts for beer until
you've seen that dilly dilly bull I
didn't get any agenda well I faxed went
over to you this morning
look I realized this was in 2005 but I
was working in an office then and I
remember that everyone even then
attached agendas to an email or she
could have just made a couple copies
considering they work at a goddamn paper
company this does however mean that
there's going to be downsizing this does
not seem like a conversation you would
have with Pam and Attendance taking
notes oh that's not appropriate and yet
instead of immediately picking up the
phone Michael just leaves it on speaker
because situation comedy has to continue
to mine the situation for comedy I guess
convenient inappropriate caller
commenting on Jan is convenient and
inappropriate also Todd Packer is not
voiced by David Koechner in this episode
hash tag not my Packard so what is
downsizing
well for the few people that saw it they
went in expecting a clever satire on the
current social climate with Matt Damon
and instead got preached to about water
conservation and oh you mean fire people
we've got Hitler jokes y'all something
just came up two minutes thank you very
much what are you doing look I can't
always defend white but I'd say he's put
up with enough of this bull did you see
how much of Jim was on his desk does he
need all those files for this one phone
call one word two syllables demarcation
pretty sure that's four syllables well I
get this is probably part of the humor I
am sitting this because I have to take
the time to count that doubt it's really
beyond words it's really incalculable
man I don't know how much of Steve
Carell's dialogue was improvised in this
show but I choose to believe it's around
90% and because Michael is a iconic
character I'm gonna be grudgingly remove
a sip but seriously Jim right if I left
what would I do with all this useless
information my head
use it to woo Emily Blunt Jim said mixed
berries the office gets a lot of credit
for launching the fake documentary
sitcom craze but it should also take the
blame right I mean some of them saw look
at the reboot of the Muppets or the last
six seasons of Modern Family so great
tell him about the the kung-fu and the
car and everything
Dwight talks about the car but never the
colonel fool I'm a volunteer sheriff's
deputy on the weekends just kind of
feels like this line of dialogue might
be responsible for that reality show
with Steven Seagal as a sheriff and that
is most definitely asset 20 past five I
stuff to do my fascist damnit this pilot
was way too fax focus for the time frame
in which it was filmed like this plot
point worked but it was way back in 1990
and die hard to do you like the Jamie
Kennedy experiment had Punk'd and all
that kind of stuff okay not only does he
like it BJ Novak was actually on Punk'd
which is all fine and dandy except now
it means that show exists in this
universe where the actor BJ Novak exists
who has the same exact DNA as Ryan so
really it's the whole space-time
continuum that's about to be punked
listen have a nice weekend yeah
definitely you too
enjoy Jim and Pam might be cute together
but will they or won't they storylines
that go on for multiple seasons rarely
our good thing that'll never happen
[Music]
this episode does not contain a Bernard
or Kapur or flenderson can't stand the
sight of blood not so much it's a paper
cut one does not simply walk into Mordor
so this is my kingdom far as he I can
say everything the light touches people
seem to like me because I am polite and
I'm rarely late I like to eat ice cream
and I really enjoy a nice pair of slacks
how about a magic track I say bring it
on oh it's already been Bharati